did you miss me
I miss me well I mean like this I missed
the series what's up guys my name is
China welcome back to the ray tracing
series it's been a while since the last
episode I know hoping to get back into
it today we're going to be talking about
emission and emissive materials and
we're also going to take the opportunity
to hopefully get in and clean some stuff
up so to put it simply emissive
materials are simply materials that emit
light every other kind of material we've
been working with and I say material
than quotes because our materials are
really quite basic at the moment but
nevertheless every material that we've
talked about thus far absorbs light what
that means is that when we have a ray
that comes in and it hits a surface such
as this table for example that light
that's coming in from that like window
behind me when it hits this table the
table absorbs some portion of that light
and the rest of it is reflected
somewhere now we've touched on this
Loosely in the past but the some way
that it's reflected to will be
determined by the actual kind of micro
facet model of the surface so rougher
surfaces will scatter more Rays kind of
in different directions smoother
surfaces will more or less just reflect
acted along the normal now in an actual
Ray Tracer it's done typically in
Reverse so the ray comes from the camera
which might be like our eye looking at
this table and what we're basically
doing is reflecting this Ray that's
coming from the camera in some kind of
Direction and then to kind of simulate
the material absorbing some of that
light we have this multiplier variable
which we're halving every single Bounce
That kind of simulates the absorption of
that light because eventually that Ray
will go out somewhere and it will hit
the sky oh it seems very simple there's
only two spheres so it'll get there
rather quickly and that sky is kind of
the light source that we have but since
the material absorbs some portion of the
light we kind of reduce the overall
light power using that multiplier now we
also have this kind of directional light
that we created it's a little bit of a
hack but it's just a way to provide some
kind of direct light to our pixels as
well essentially so to summarize what's
happening is every time the ray hits an
actual object I.E one of our spheres it
loses some energy it doesn't gain energy
and and in fact every material that we
have that is anonymisive in the real
world will always absorb some portion of
light energy I'm not sure if it's like a
hundred percent physically impossible it
sounds like it probably should be but at
the very least I can confidently say
that it will never increase the light
energy again unless it's an emissive
material in fact that's one of the most
important rules of a physically based
renderer energy conservation you can't
wind up with more energy after you hit a
surface the light energy will always
kind of diminish obviously it depends on
the surface and even like the surface
color black will absorb more than white
white will reflect more light but even
something like a perfectly shiny mirror
it does lose some kind of level of
energy that's why if you put like
mirrors facing each other so that you
get that kind of like infinite mirror
Corridor as you look into all of the
mirrored Reflections you'll notice that
they're getting darker and darker
because even though the mirrors are very
very reflective they are still absorbing
some light right so materials and
surfaces absorb some kind of light and
then reflect the remaining light energy
and that makes up our scene but what if
we had a material that actually did
increase light energy what if the
material itself is kind of like emissive
and glowing that is essentially a
material that acts as a light source I
think it's interesting that in kind of
renderers and not just Ray tracers but
rasterized renderers as well we have
these kind of different light types we
might have a directional light a point
light a spotlight an area light whatever
what's interesting is that none of these
really exist at least in that form in
the real world like they're all
completely fictional a directional light
like what's a directional light it's a
it's a light with no position it's just
a direction that clearly cannot
physically exist in the real world but
what it is is a really good model to
approximate how sunlight works and how
the Sun works because the sun is this
huge powerful light source that's so so
far away that really doesn't have a
position as long as you're in one kind
of position and don't go too far around
the world it's kind of like a light that
it covers an infinitely large area and
it only really has One Direction a point
light is a light source that is
infinitely small and just emits light in
all directions like that obviously
cannot exist because you can't have a
light that physically has no volume or
Surface area it's infinitely small but
it just creates light somehow that's
magic that's fiction over here I have a
light it has a filament and that
filament when current flows through it
will actually create lice so let's think
about this a little bit deeper this
filament is just a normal kind of
material right now it's just a material
that absorbs light in this state but if
I turn this on
Suddenly It's emitting light right so
here it is just absorbing light like any
other material we've talked about thus
far
and then suddenly it's able to actually
emit light now if you're in some kind of
like game engine or maybe like a 3D
program like blender and you wanted to
model this you might just create a light
like in our Ray Tracer at the moment
you'd be like okay well I want this
light source to be here I'll just create
like a point light or something but my
point really that I'm trying to drive
home here is that this is kind of just
an emissive material so emissive
materials
are basically lights and in fact I'd go
as far as to say that basically any
light in the real world is just an
emissive material the reason why we have
lights like Point lights and directional
lights is because it's a lot simpler to
kind of model that version of reality
especially in rasterized graphics but in
a ray Tracer where we are physically
just tracing rays and actually doing
light calculations based on physics
essentially this actually makes a lot
more sense and so what we're going to do
today is jump into our code base extend
our materials to support emission and
then Implement that into our renderer so
that we can actually have materials that
emit light and in fact we can turn
everything else off our stupid
directional light that was just kind of
there as a test and then our Skylight we
can turn all that off and just rely on
materials that emit light to light our
scene but first before we jump in I want
to thank brilliant.org for sponsoring
this video brilliant.org is a fantastic
sponsor for this series because they
have in my opinion opinion the best math
courses on the internet and math is
vitally important foray tracing I would
say like for programming in general but
like I mean if we take a look at some of
the code that we're writing here you
know like the sphere intersection
knowing things like the quadratic
formula solving these equations and like
what to do with like the multiple
solutions that you might get that kind
of stuff is really really helpful and I
promise you that if you just take a
moment to try and understand this stuff
you're going to have a lot more fun with
the code you right because you'll be
able to understand it on a deeper level
and thus extend it and tweak it much
more easily the worst thing to do is
just to try and like tweak the numbers
until something magically works and then
it might not work in all cases because
you have no idea what you're doing if
you're completely new to math start with
Brilliance Everyday Math course it's a
really good gentle introduction if you
want to get deeper into the kind of
stuff we're doing here brilliant have
everything from algebra to linear
algebra to even calculus which we'll
touch on later and the reason why I say
Berlin is one of my favorite places on
the internet to do this kind of stuff is
because all of their courses are really
engaging they have these widgets that
you can play with to actually visualize
how everything's working that can be
really really helpful to help you
understand and then they'll also
continually quiz you which in my opinion
is vital to ensuring that you actually
retain the information that you're
learning and guess what they have a
30-day free trial just go to
brilliant.org the channel link will be
in the description below give it a go go
through some of these math courses and
see if you like them and if you do
brilliant have been nice enough to offer
the first 200 subscribers 20 off an
annual membership huge thank you as
always to brilliant.org for sponsoring
this video okay so the first thing that
I want to do here is I basically want to
go back into Walnut app.cpp and extend
our kind of materials that we have here
to actually support emission now there's
a few different ways that we can do this
the simplest way is probably just to
create like a float called like emission
or something what I'm going to do though
is create two variables there's going to
be an emission power and then there's
going to be a separate Effect 3 called
emission color and this could just be
zero like just black to begin with but
the reason why I'm doing this is because
you can technically have a material that
emits a different color to what it is
and this kind of model allows us to do
that and the reason why I've also split
this up because we could obviously this
is a vek3 it doesn't have to be between
zero and one kind of for each component
it could be anything is just to make the
kind of I'm going integration a little
bit easier because I want to treat this
as like a color edit so we have like a
normal color panel that we can choose a
color but then this will kind of be a
multiplier on top of that that will
really just get multiplied so basically
what I'm saying is we'll multiply these
two together when we do the actual
calculation and so because we're going
to want to use it that way I'm going to
make a glm vac 3 function here called
get emission const and it will just
return emission color times emission
power okay so the next step is going to
be back in Walnut app we're going to
expose this stuff into I am gooey just
so that we can play with it so we have
over here all of our materials being
drawn uh in terms of like our controls
fine GUI so let's make a color edit here
called emission color can get rid of the
rest of this and make sure that we use
the glm value pointer over here and then
we'll have emission power which will
just be afloat uh I'm not gonna so we'll
make it from zero to FLT Max which is
just like the max float floating point
value if you just set a minimum I am
gooey at least this version of I am
gooey will not kind of it won't do
anything at all so you have to kind of
set both Min and Max if you actually
wanted to enforce that kind of those
bounds
um and we of course don't want this to
be negative so zero is the the lowest
and 0.05 can be the kind of speed at
which we change that if we actually drag
Okay cool so that looks pretty good
um what we can do here if we want is we
can set some initial emission but I'm
not going to worry about that for now
let's add another sphere uh that is
maybe this has a radius of one that's
maybe like two along the X and we'll
give it a material index of Two And so
I'll just make another material here
maybe we'll call it Orange sphere we'll
set the Albedo to be quite warm maybe
like 0.8 0.5 0.2 something like that
hopefully that'll be a nice orange uh
roughness I'll just leave it that and so
what we're going to do with this guy
which yes I need to rename to Orange
sphere is we will actually set uh an
emission color I'll just set it to be
the Albedo to begin with and then
emission power I can set to like two or
something for now again we should be
able to just change all of this inside
I'm GUI like inside our actual interface
so it's not going to matter too much
okay so let's hit F5 we're going to see
obviously hopefully an orange sphere but
with no emission because we don't have a
mission all right uh and there we go uh
that is looking quite bright but that's
okay for now let's go in and first of
all just remove the directional light
that we have so if I go to the renderer
over here inside our per pixel function
which of course is like the main
function where we do everything uh these
are kind of our light calculations so we
have this kind of light Direction light
intensity I'm just going to get rid of
this and then obviously sphere color
times equals light intensity we can get
rid of and since vehicle is only used
here I can just use material Albedo
directly just to make the code a little
bit more simple so actually removing
code we're making this more simple let's
hit F5 and just see the effect without
any kind of directional light okay cool
looks kind of cool looks very bright in
fact looks kind of like we barely have
any diffuse light so let's go in and
maybe change our model a little bit
because what we're doing here is kind of
like a weird hybrid between diffuse and
specular light transport and I don't
like it
so what I'm going to do is actually if
we go into random and say this is Walnut
random we have this in unit sphere
function which really all it does is it
generates a vect3 in kind of like a
negative one to one range right across
obviously three axes so X Y and Z and
then it normalizes it which will kind of
make the length you know 0.7 I guess of
each component and we wind up with
basically a vector that is in 3D space
somewhere inside a unit sphere this is
actually a really handy function it's
not a great implementation because this
will use the random number generator
it's going to be a little bit slower
than something we'll switch to in the
future which will actually be something
that we can use inside our Vulcan Ray
tracing shaders when we get there that's
going to be like I don't know at least
five times faster probably than what
we're doing here and the other problem
is it's in a unit sphere which isn't a
great kind of domain I guess that we
want our random numbers to be in because
what's happening at the moment is if a
ray hits this what we're doing is we're
reflecting it just by the normal and
then the blue is is kind of the output
right we're also kind of jittering it
based on the roughness of the surface
and that's kind of creating this that's
not how diffuse light works this is
mostly used for specular and obviously
you'll have like the micro facet model
and really this is like the brdf which
is the bi-directional reflectance
distribution function but basically what
I'm saying is for a diffuse lighting
calculation obviously like what we're
trying to do is instead of setting Rays
from the light we're sending Rays from
the camera so if we do in fact hit this
we have to account for the possibility
that actually in orange light might come
from here
light might come from all directions it
really will come from all directions the
only directions that can't come in
really is from underneath because this
is kind of like an opaque I guess
surface and that doesn't make any sense
if you go into like subsurface
scattering and bssdfs that's a different
story but for our kind of scenario that
can't be possible so what we kind of
like to do is look at a hemisphere and
just be like okay well for each path
that we Trace let's send a random Ray
somewhere within this hemisphere what
I'm doing and what I'm going to propose
we do right now is we're just going to
use this in unit sphere function which
technically includes all of this stuff
but it's not really technically going to
create a worse image or an inaccurate
image it's just going to send out more
rays that aren't as important that will
kind of not contribute anything and it
will make our rendering take longer but
in the future when we look at important
sampling and stuff we'll revamp this
whole thing anyway this is just so
complicated isn't it I'm trying to I'm
trying to not complicate it for myself
maybe I should explain less so uh in
unit sphere is what we can use basically
is what I'm saying so let's take this so
we currently have just glm reflect Ray
Direction which is our incoming
Direction along that world normal as I
mentioned uh and then we Jitter it and
then we get kind of this output rate but
instead what we could do is when we hit
something so I'll just comment this out
so we can see what it was before we can
just set this kind of New Direction our
new diffuse direction to be Walnut
random in unit sphere so this will just
pick a new random direction for us to go
in sounds kind of stupid but let's take
a look at the result okay so this is the
result we're seeing like a bunch of
light obviously reflected from
everywhere it is kind of overall bright
to make this a little bit better what we
can actually do is bias it to be in the
direction of the world normal so if we
take this random Vector that's in the
unit sphere but then we add the world
normal to it right so we have the normal
added to it and then obviously we take
the whole thing and normalize it we're
kind of pushing it to be in the
direction of the world normal but it's
still has some variance to it so to do
that we can normalize payload.world
normal plus this kind of random in unit
sphere uh Jitter if you will and you can
see what that's done it's made it ever
so subtly different in terms of this
kind of uh Pink I guess being reflected
off of this uh blue sphere now there's
still way too much light energy though
so let's fix that at the moment we have
these two things up here and they're
very important we have a color and we
have a multiplier if we look at what
this does color we're adding kind of
Albedo to it which is already a little
bit wrong because we do we can't add
anything to it the reason why we're
doing this is because this kind of had
to do with the directional light that we
had coming in directional lights
obviously add light so this kind of
makes sense what I'm going to do just
for clarity is I'm actually going to
change these variables a little bit I'm
going to rename this color to be light
so now it kind of makes sense like when
you see light plus equals this it tells
you that you're actually adding light
power and that immediately hopefully
like kind of looks wrong right this kind
of makes sense like we're adding a sky
color because the sky is kind of
supposed to be a light but this looks
wrong so that's good multiplier okay a
few things here first of all this is
just a float at the moment what it
really should be is a vect three why
because not to get too deep into this
but obviously like we have a spectrum of
colors we have this kind of wavelength
of light energy when light hits
something materials will actually absorb
certain wavelengths of light so if we
look at my water bottle here this Orange
right why is this Orange it's because
when the light hits it it absorbs pretty
much all of the blue light and it only
reflects light that is kind of red and
green of course it reflects a little bit
of blue light but predominantly it's
this color because when the light hits
it this material is capable of absorbing
certain wavelengths of light and
reflecting other wavelengths so that we
can actually see them so in a similar
way it doesn't make sense for our
multiplier to just be a float so I'm
going to to make it of x3 we're going to
initialize it here 2 1 same as it was
when it was a float and this multiplier
there's a few different names that we
could use for it it could be like the
color of our Ray in a way because as the
ray bounces around and materials absorb
certain colors we're left with whatever
like the remaining light energy in that
rate is I'm going to rename it to
something called contribution and that's
basically going to be like the amount of
color contribution that our Ray carries
so at the moment we're halving it but
let's change the way that this is
actually calculated and it's going to be
really simple but the effect is going to
be so dramatic we're simply going to
stop increasing light and instead change
our contribution to be multiplied by
material.albedo so what are we doing
here well remember this is starting at
one so if we have something that's red
what's the Albedo going to be one zero
zero so if we multiply contribution with
this what's happening is that these
channels are basically being canceled
out they're being absorbed and then this
kind of Channel or color wavelength is
reflecting a hundred percent of it so
therefore we will see red light now
notice this is times equals and as long
as this stuff is in between zero and one
and this starts at one we will always
diminish we will always either diminish
or remain exactly the same as in this
case if we even had something slightly
less red it would actually absorb which
means we would progressively get darker
that's good we shouldn't be able to add
light unless it's a light source or an
emissive material so by doing this with
our little uh contribution and then
remember so we're not adding light
anyway we're returning a light at the
end here but we're just kind of
multiplying with the Albedo to get the
contribution the only place where we add
the light is over here and we do Sky
color times contribution let's see what
that looks like all right check it out
doesn't that look cool
this looks so dramatically different and
this is diffuse only so no Reflections
no specular we'll get to that later but
what we're seeing here I think is pretty
cool I mean if we zoom in a little bit
you can see the pink kind of reflected
here you can see obviously the influence
of this blue thing up here you can see
the shadow that's been created here this
kind of natural ambient occlusion and it
really is ambient occlusion here because
this Skylight is kind of like an ambient
light source it doesn't have a direction
or anything like that now I also notice
here that for some reason the emission
the emission color is correct but the
emission power is zero so I must have
made a little typo yeah okay emission
power I use metallic so this should be
emission power let's quickly fix that up
and so now what I would like to do is
I'd like to actually get this kind of
emission power and this this sphere
that's supposed to be missive to
actually emit light how do we do that
that sounds pretty complicated doesn't
it no no not at all because guess what
we have to do all we have to do is take
this light and it doesn't matter by the
way if we do it first or second because
they're not really going to be exclusive
to each other but all we have to do is
is take this light and just add the
emission from it so we're generating
light basically and again this light
isn't really going to do much at this
stage you could multiply this by the way
with material Albedo so that you can
still kind of absorb some of that but we
won't do that for now for anonymmissive
materials this will just add zeros or
won't do anything but if something if
something's emitting light we're
actually kind of creating more light and
so obviously that raid that contributes
to a final pixel will have a brighter
pixel and everything along its path will
also contribute to that so let's hit F5
and take a look at that we now have
basically a light source over here now
if you were expecting to see like you
know a glowing a glowing sphere like
Bloom that's not going to happen here
because that kind of glow that's a
post-process effect just like it is in a
rasterized renderer we would need to
basically Implement Bloom the same way
because it's kind of like a camera
effect so this actually is correct now
to make this effect a bit more dramatic
let's just get rid of our Skylight so
what I'm going to do is just get rid of
this comment it out so now the only
place where we're actually able to
gather light because light stars are
zero the only place where we're able to
gather light is if we have an emissive
material so without that our scene would
just be black but since we have an
emissive material check that out how
cool is that let's play around with this
scene a little bit so what I'm going to
do is just grab this sphere which is I
think this one up here I'm going to turn
off accumulate just so that we can play
with these controls because I don't have
them resetting everything let's move it
like I don't know back kind of over here
I'm going to make it way bigger so that
it's kind of like a sun
uh
continue moving it like back here maybe
make it even bigger and then let's hit
accumulate now we can also play with the
emission power if we want so two let's
make it like 20 reset and take a look at
that isn't that beautiful I just think
that looks really really cool let's
maybe fly over a little bit to here
and if we kind of just give it some time
to accumulate as well I'm going to leave
this running for like two minutes or so
and we'll see what it looks like okay so
this is about two minutes in you can see
it's definitely much less noisy you can
also see the kind of light energy here
reflecting onto the ground from this
sphere which is pretty cool and look at
this absolutely beautiful soft Shadow
like just try and Achieve that in a
rasterize surrender am I right it's so
difficult but you it just happens
naturally and that's one of the
beautiful things about Ray tracing like
did we have to implement Shadows like no
no we don't obviously for like
directional light sources and when we
have basically things that aren't
emissive if we're trying to model those
traditional light sources we will have
to do some kind of Ray Trace shadows and
maybe some other algorithms they're a
lot more simple than like Shadow maps
and actually getting Shadow maps to look
good in a rasterized pipeline however
you can see that we just get these kind
of amazing looking Shadows just for free
and that's just the beauty of Ray
tracing and what you could do absolutely
is you could just make an entire scene
with this like as I I mentioned emissive
materials that's basically how lights
work in the real world so there's no
reason why you even need lights really
like you could get away with quite a lot
by just using this now the biggest thing
this is missing at the moment is the
whole specular component and obviously
like the way that we're doing this kind
of diffuse rendering is also not really
100 correct and it will change depending
on whether or not our material is
metallic so there's a few there's still
a ways to go in terms of physically
based rendering but honestly I just
think this is just beautifully simple
like I mean if we look at the code that
we have here like I mean this is our per
pixel function it's like it's literally
this
this is basically our entire Ray Tracer
excluding like the sphere intersection
and you can see just how cool it is I
mean of course we could get rid of this
and then this is just what we're dealing
with like it's just amazing it's amazing
that that is really all it takes to make
something as cool as that so I hope you
guys enjoyed this video if you did
please don't forget to hit like button I
hope you're excited the ray tracing
series is back if you are definitely
show your support in the comments below
don't forget to check out brilliant.org
channel link will be in the description
below and I will see you guys next time
goodbye